[Musique]
après traque la pentecôte
des milliers d'automobilistes ont repris
la route cette fois encore tous ne sont
pas revenus
or les accidents de la route non pas
pour cause qu'un hasard ou une
défaillance il y à aussi l'alcool mais
si l'ivresse caractérisé n'appelle aucun
commentaire il n'en va pas de même des
simples pause alcoolisées on ne se méfie
pas assez de l'agréable état d'euphorie
procuré par quelques modestes verre
[Musique]
d'alcool ainsi répandus dans le sang
provoque pourtant la perte de 30% de
l'acuité visuelle de 38% de l'acuité
auditive
[Musique]
il n'est jusqu'aux joyeux repas prise
innocemment même famille qu'il puisse
transformer une sortie dominicale en
voyage pour l'éternité
alors en prenant le volant méfiez-vous
du bien-être suspect que procure
l'alcool
[Musique]